hello everyone
welcome to the talk on geometric scene
in olympia geometry
i'm sean hoyne i work for warframe alpha
for localization system and scientific
systems
during my work and my hobby
i actually use wolfram language a lot
in various kind of research and one of
them
is eucalydian geometry and i'm also very
interested in
some advanced topics in geometry on
a different level of a math context
so
i also contribute uh quite often
on the community so if you are
new to mathematica or you have been
using community for a while
i sometimes just write articles based on
interesting math problems and solve that
step by step with the wolfram language
and then publish on the community to
share that with other enthusiasts
and hobbyists or even advanced users
to see how to use wall from language in
solving these practical problems
also i feel this is a quite interesting
experience for me to see how
this very powerful platform
to interact with uh some uh real world
contest
problems and how to take advantage of
the
um of the platform to help me understand
a lot better
of those heart problems
even for some imo level
problems it's a
wolfram language is very powerful to
visualize it
and to analyze everything inside
step by step okay uh let's
start the the presentation
um okay this is just a little background
of myself and how
i find that those problems will be
discussed
in today's talk um one of the website i
use very often
is challenging it's here
it's very nice website
that curated a lot of competition level
unplanned problems the other one is
tittle's book
so um titus um titu
and risco he i think he used to be the
chairman
of american math society and he has
many interesting
um textbooks about uh geometry
and all kinds of uh topics one of them
is complex number from a to z
so this is a a book i think is very
friendly to newcomers and to
advance the math olympiad uh
math olympiad computers so it builds up
from very simple complex number two
geometric topics
so i also use that uh to uh to test
um warfarin language ability on those uh
interesting problems uh the other one is
uh michael pence youtube
channel so this is a instructor from
randolph college and
two of the problem i'm going to show
today is from his video
and i think his video is getting very
popular right now like
80k views on the
one italian math problem i'm going to
talk later
and the other is a very relaxing
geometric problem i'm going to show that
uh in one of in one of
my blog posts and he also has a
collection of nice problems here and
i think that's a very good resource to
learn and i
kind of use wolfram language as my
homework to to practice
a lot of the problem-solving skills
based on
his instruction so yeah let's start to
see
the uh real world problems and i'm going
to show
how to use uh the um
the very specific function in wolfram
language called geometric scene
and uh to construct to tackle these
geometric problems
first let me just quickly summarize uh
the features i feel you know advantage
over
of a german synthetic geometry towards
enzyme warfare
one wolfram language over uh kind of cad
or geogebra cad is kind of generic for
like
computer aided design so usually you
have a blueprint that you
point points and connect dots and do the
uh problem solving um so
geometricing is kind of different from
that uh
it is a lot like uh what you see is what
you get
uh i won't say the visualize part but
more about the
how you code the geometric scene based
on a given problem
it's basically just like you type the
nature language input
in a slightly modified way so that
the geometry scene will automatically
give you
a setup and then you use random instance
to create a configuration based on the
the possible result that satisfying all
the conditions
so the code is very similar to
the problems you see in the contest or
traditional euclidean geometry book
so you don't really need uh to
understand
uh wolfram language to a very very deep
uh level it's just uh very
self-explanatory
uh the third one is uh very important is
like
the triangle construct and the triangle
center function
so these two functions give really good
shortcuts to
create sevens and standards for example
i want to create an in center of a
triangle
so i think in geogebra you need to just
follow definition
and create a uh three angular bisectors
first and uh the concurrency
is uh is the uh in center right
but in uh if you have like a large
configuration you need to do that um
many times so that's kind of
tedious to do that in in geogebra in
triangle construct you basically give it
a triangle and say i want this one i
want an incentive
or circumcenter so you can automatically
do that and
it gives you both numerical value and
the symbolic map
so that's really really easy to use
and the geometric scene is also like a
equation solver this will be seen in the
first example
uh in the problem in my problem list
so if you are given some um
quite complicated uh configuration and
uh
you are told that some of the angles
inside or segments
are of the same value or some are
like twice trisector and angle so this
usually very hard to do in
you know the the cadillac software which
is
more like you do that with uh
a straight straight edge and a compass
so the kind of traditional way but
you they are great at the projective
properties like for example uh you have
four points
on circle and you know their inscribed
angles are the same
it's quite a famous uh property but if
because regardless the position of the
four points
on the circle uh it always satisfy this
condition so
uh with the catalytic thing you draw
just door random circle and put a random
points on that and
probably easy but if i specify you know
the
um the angle must be some degree or
uh there's uh some like segmentation
requirements for that
uh it's harder to put this side of this
kind of cuff
constraints in in geogebra so this is
something i feel like
um geometric scene plays a really really
important role and big roles
in solving these type problems and
finally if you uh
analyze the problem carefully and you
find out oh
okay i understand the conditions every
step of that
um you can work with that with uh
animation or typically manipulate
functions
so that will give you um very good
control of generating
a random random um
or uh continuously changing
configuration
for example just like a nine point
circle so this is a
example from the demonstration web
package
so it works all everything works
perfectly together so you don't need to
worry too much about you know if this is
like isolated
island in in warfare language it does
not work with
other things but it's not true it just
works with
all the uh basic functions
yeah just typically in we're working
with this thing
you just don't need to understand the
wolfram language too much
okay now let's uh take a look at some
examples
from the real context so let abc be a
triangle such that a b equal to 9 and
ac equal to 7 and then let d be the
midpoint of segment bc
let x be a point on segment a b such
that dx is perpendicular to a b
and let y be a point on segment ac such
that d
y is perpendicular to ac so if a x
equal to six what's the length of a y
okay
typically for this problem um you
can for example draw uh if you work with
a geogebra you can probably draw a line
with
a b equal to given length and ac is on
uh a circle so this uh radius is
like seven and then uh the hard part is
uh how do you
just uh draw everything you know satisfy
the following three conditions at the
same time so once d
is the middle point and the other is uh
uh like
the problem two perpendicular conditions
so this is usually
um very very tricky to do to do that if
you do not compute the result before you
draw
everything but in geometric scene you
don't have to
uh it works just like uh um
a translation machine you you have a
euclidean distance
and the midpoint is like telling d is
midpoint of bc
and uh x and the y are a point
between the two endpoints of segment a b
and ac
and then i have a geometric assertion
that is uh
going to give the confinements of uh
of points uh objective relations
sometimes the points or sometimes
lines or circles so you can do that uh
with a
geometric assertion and then finally
it's uh
given that ax equal to six you can do
the euclidean distance
ax equal to six so this gives you uh
all the uh sort of a list of conditions
that works
uh as the um the basic
uh description uh same as the original
problem
and then because uh um the c d x y are
unknown so you give it a random instance
for it to solve it
so for example let me just quickly bring
out the
uh the documents for that so this
is exactly even like a new problem it
works exactly like
the uh the basic examples in geometric
scene
so i use in my example i use the third
template
so given some points and then
given a list of a hypothesis to solve
for that
the reason that i need to give it some
point is for example if you take a look
at the first example in the
in the documentation uh you see in the
geometry
scene you have abc and the planar angle
is 30 for angle uh abc
so um you if you give the random
instance because there are many
triangles satisfying this condition it
actually the triangle can point to
everywhere
so i give it some point uh some
constraints so that uh it just
looks like a configuration or a textbook
you know if a
bass is like kind of uh
parallel to the x-direction and uh um
c is point either up or down based on
the
chirality of the or clockwiseness of a
of this configuration but i don't have
to specify here
but if you do that multiple times it
definitely sometimes you'll see
uh c points downward and or uh yeah you
can just
choose random instance multiple times
but if you don't like it
you need a specified configuration
so you can just give it a random seed
for example
in options you go to random c it will
give you
a specific uh configuration that you can
repeat every time
so that that's a very convenient way to
fix a configuration that happens to
uh you know meet your visualization
requirement so uh yes this is uh
like you saw for the uh geometric scene
and what's the length of a y is simply
computed by
uh this way uh so this is the euclidean
distance
uh a y so you need to know a y but a u
and
y are symbols here it's not a given any
values
so you can just grab um
[Music]
the value of the the numerical values of
all the coordinates with
the points attributes of the geometry
scene object
so this thing itself is not graphics
it's a
it's a geometric scene object so it
contains um
attribute points so you can just uh
evaluate that it will give you a list of
uh
thing just look like this so it's the
numerical result
and then it will automatically replace
the symbols inside euclidean distance
and give you the result
okay so uh the reason i think is that
usually you know
in this type of problem um the numerical
values are
kind of small it's usually between 0 and
99
so i can safely just rationalize it and
i
assume this is the exact value of
of this a y i'm going to solve
okay let's see the next
problem uh this is a a problem
also found on a math competition
in kazakhstan uh john john kohl who's
supposed to be a kazakhstan
mathematician and
his name is uh uh kind of famous over
there in the name
uh math only based on the uh the surname
of this mathematician
and the problem stays like this a point
is the end point that the point m
is the midpoint of side ac and of the
triangle abc
and the point d on the side of bc is
such that
b m and b m a equal to d m c
and it turns out that c d plus d dm
equal to bn
and prove that we have this the sum of
these two angles
equal to a given angle so this type of
problem also
include you know kind of constrained
that
it's hard to come up with uh uh compass
and the straight edge method
um because of course if you
went through go through all the proof
and you realize oh okay that's
you do that reversely if you know the
result and that's a different
story but in in the problem usually we
have to do that
in the forward manner so the same thing
is
using the geometrical scene and i given
point two so because there is no
specification of the length of the
of the side of the side of triangle i
just give it usually two or three is
it's an easy number to find and this
make sure
ac is on x axis and y is pointing
something
somewhere vertically so
and then i need to specify d
and are the unknown points because their
coordinates
are not given explicitly just like b so
i don't put anything behind them and
then i try
uh i draw a triangle abc and
in in which m is the point middle point
of ac
and line line bdc is because
um the d there are two ways to do that
one is you do
d is uh element of line ac of line bc or
bdc is like collinear thing you can you
can write directly
this would basically draw another line
so sort of uh covering bc
but that's not a bigger problem
and then you need to specify the
equality of the angles
this is a planar angle bma just
read it like that and playing planet
angles dmc
is this one okay and then i have
uh the equality of the sum of segments
to
another the length of the other segment
so this just
looks like the problem itself so
it's really not programming or just
just coding but just the translation
part so you have everything set up and
give it a random instance so this is uh
this is the power of
of this kind of configurations because
absolutely if you take a look at this uh
confirmation
and then take a look at the uh the
diagram you probably need to feel like
this is slightly different
from this one because this in this
problem
you specify the length and the
perpendicular uh condition here that
everything you can draw is a
configuration congruent to this one
but uh in this one apparently if you
think about it you uh twist the angle
here it probably look a little bit
different
so this is a sort of random instance
thing i feel like
it inspires when you know the the solver
i mean the contest or the learner of
this problem
to i think a lot deeper than the
the simple drawing process of uh of the
problem
so um yes so you now you have the basic
configuration but if you look at in this
problem and uh
uh look at these conditions probably you
you might have a rough idea about how to
uh how to prove this so because
i have a md uh yeah dm plus cd
so this line or the the sum is same as
uh bn uh it looks like if i
extend an md to somewhere and then
the sun somewhere e and d e equals dc
i might have something to transfer the
angles and
the equality of the lens segments
and that's summations so this is
something i can do
just to add uh some lines uh in the
in in the problem to make it sort of uh
like auxiliarized in the real proof
sequence you do
paper you do that with a paper and
pencil
so you just do that um
and specify um specified like bm
uh it is vm so this basically if you add
bm it creates a triangle here
in this one i actually don't have the
triangle here
just the dashed line comes from the
planar angle
function and and then if you create
this geometric scene with the same
same sim setup just add a point e
and it creates a nice diagram with the
auxiliaries
here um the other powerful feature
for geometry is there's a function that
you can wrap it
with that so this will give you the um
some of the critical ideas that you can
help but
they can help your you to prove the
problem
so here is uh once you have the
triangles uh it
would automatically give you some
conjectures
and these two are congruent so which are
which is the key point of the proof
and the other one is um sort of this
planar angle transformation so this is
like angle chasing that
basically transfer abn and b e
c and d c e to um
to a set up that is actually showing the
uh based on the congress so base
m transfer to ecm and uh
dcm is basically sitting there
and but this angle transferred through
the isosceles
triangle of dec and then you have the
sum of this angle plus uh
this angle equal to this angle so e c
n and the ecm is exactly dna
so i also have uploaded the file to the
to the file section impedable so you can
download
that to review the procedure of the
proof
and also i the thing uh the feature
i like a lot is the hatch fitting so
this gives me
a very nice way to highlight the
isosceles triangle that i'm going to
show
uh in my proof so this is actually a
very
very nice um feature that introduced
after version 12.
i think there is a lot of way to use
this feature but
you clean the geometry i feel like this
is great um
sometimes if i have lightness for
example a lot of triangles
or a lot of circles i'm going to show
the
congruence or consequent properties
this way to highlight
individual components is very useful and
won't
uh give you like confusion if you draw
too many lines
and this also i would say colorblind
friendliness
you you don't really need to you know
draw like use 20 colors in a diagram to
highlight something
so this is uh something i feel like if
you use
a hatch filling uh if you work with uh
euclidean geometries
uh you can use this hatch feeling to
help visualization
a lot okay the third problem
is uh also like very cute um it's
a problem got many views i've shown on
michael pence channel uh with adk
this is an italian mo problem so their
hexagon has
all its angles equal and the length of
four consecutive sides are five
three seven six seven respectively find
the length of the remaining two edges
so uh this is also very hard to draw
directly
um the but
in our case it's uh still you know can
be done
with these uh very very straightforward
way
to to to verbally
describe the the situation in wolverine
language
um so first uh i would say is that we
need to use
a property that uh all the sum of all
interior angles in a convex hexagon
is a 720 so this is a um
something very well uh documented
in wolfram language and typically from
alpha
so you type a double equal sign in the
cell
it gives you the spiky thing
and then you type a hexagon and it gives
you the
some basic information about that and
you can just check the properties
if you want the part itself just like
myself
you can just click the plus sign in the
format
formatted part it will give you
a code look like this
and you can extract the property from
from the problem from the wall from
alpha
uh pod list so and then um
using that i can just quickly uh say
i i have a you know a list of what
equalities
i can express in in terms of a planar
angle uh planar angle
and everything should equal to 720
divided by six that's 120 degrees which
is uh
uh two thirds of two-thirds of a pi
so this for the angles uh you can just
write
you know the planet angle equal to
this and this one equal to this so i
just
combine something and make it look
neater um
and then you're given the conditions for
a distance to satisfy the
length requirements so it's just like
this
and then i need to add a generic
assertions here because i wanna
you know you can definitely flip f2
somewhere so it does not
require it does not satisfy convexity
requirement so i just put it here just
make sure
everything is uh sitting on the right
order so
the hexagon is convex
so yeah you can just uh put everything
inside and uh now this is just the
configuration
uh in the problem and then you just need
to
grab the points and find the exact
coordinates so um i
just put a utility function in the
notebook
it will give you it is useful to improve
this without
so the proof is rather straightforward
uh you just need to extend the site
and and then it meets um every the two
the segments will meet at the vertices
vertices of a
larger equilateral triangle so
um and then you can just assume some of
the length is unknown and
use uh very simple algebras
to find the required length uh
symbolically this gives you
accurate result it's not the
the numeric approximation so
uh you can just review the notebook or
follow
michael pence video to see how it is
approved
okay let's see the next one
the extenders and auto center other
other triangles
so this part is uh i do not use
geometric scenes something i can
compare to the former example
um so in this case um i
going to i'm going to show that how do
you use a triangle center with uh
with manipulate so this will give you
very
powerful way to generate some very
sophisticated uh
configurations involving object circles
and weird centers
so this one for example i give a
coordinate
of a triangle uh three vertices abc
um and then the code is actually very
uh straightforward so this basically
extract the uh
the coordinates i use associations kind
of
popular to do that after version version
11.
and then um the code is actually very
short it's just uh
um you know repeating itself you can see
that
it's the same thing uh it's a triangle
center given the three vertices
and i want to extract the uh excess and
x center
which is the intersection of
one or three bisectors one is for uh
inner angle interior angle and two four
two uh
exteriors angle so this is our this is
something you can just compute directly
from triangle center
and you do that for all three vertices
and um this is a for um uh
if you have the coordinates of the three
access centers
and then you four find the author
centers so it's just the order center of
a larger triangle
so um what what the configuration says
is um the triangle formed by
three x centers and uh um
and you have a um a smaller triangle and
you find an in center so the other
center of the
largest triangle is the same thing as
the in center of the smaller triangle
uh this is a very classical example of
how
the center and other centers working
together
and if you want to um um great animation
from that
uh it's kind of synth as the the code
above but i just uh
use um the triangle construct the other
thing is basically
i want to expand the side of the
segments to infinity for each side of
the smaller
a smaller triangle and then i have
the repeating the sides and the triangle
constructs because i
want not only the center but also the x
circle so the circle that tangent to two
sides
all the three sides and the sitting
outside um
so the same thing um applies to
these lines that connecting the
extenders
and eventually i want to um
name the the controllers as the
abcs so this is basically i want to
put a decorated controllers
so this code looks a little bit longer
than before but it's just a repeat
itself and
easy to share because it's just uh um
just text the description of the problem
uh and then this is a
syntax for locator if you uh refer to
uh manipulate a documentation it's uh
it's just a template once you just need
to do that once
uh and then i just change the appearance
of the points to
b and to c so that uh it looks very nice
it gives you the the very smooth
motion of the points and how the
concurrency
is invariant and based on the changing
position
of adc so it's very nice and this method
is usually
much faster than geometrical scene
because it does not involve anything
like equation solving it's just directly
computes
a real-time computing of all the
centers and intersections so this is a
very powerful way
to generate such sophisticated
configuration
with a minimum delay okay
okay let's take a look the last example
uh it's very interesting one from sharon
jean 2016.
it's an altitude ah of a triangle abc
bisects and medium
bm uh prove that the medians of a
triangle abm
are inside the length of a right
triangle so this problem a little tricky
and
you can just review that in depth with
the file you have
you can download it from possible so
this problem is kind of tricky because
um the
usually the triangle you draw and you
draw like
a edge and it usually does not bisect bm
ibm is like uh this one so it's the
median
it's media line uh connection averages
and the middle point of opposite uh
segments
so in general if you you draw it it
won't
intersect the exact midpoint so there is
something very special about
this triangle and you can use the same
thing
this to actually explore it and
typically i just
use a triangle center here and triangle
center
not only gives you uh the extra center
but also give you some important
points like the foot of altitude so this
is basically like
the same same thing as the problem
it's just really like the m is the
midpoint of ac
and is the midpoint of ibm
and uh in this point because
ah bisects bm um it's it means
the middle point of uh bm
is uh collinear with ad so this is
basically the setup okay
and then you you can just to find a
random instance
for this configuration and it's not
unique
so you can have two ways to prove that
thing is one
use a very algebraic way to to handle
that
the other is a very nice feature
is the demonstration project probably
you you know that for a long time
you have tons of uh good examples and
typically if i'm going to introduce a
new theorem in my presentation or blog i
just call
such a easy api
it's from source uh copy
resource project it basically just
generates this code for you and then you
run the shift
enter the notebook and give you uh the
demonstration here you can
play around and this is a more generic
way to prove the
uh this problem and gives you um
based on mandela's theorem it's very
dynamic and
you get zero length of coding just
downloading
um and then it'll show you how use that
in different two configurations in the
problems
and you can find the proper way
to uh computer compute
the the special the special property of
the point
d on segment bt bc
so yeah if um so once you
have that um everything else is
um is uh based on the proportionality of
uh
triangle similarities it's basically if
you triangle you have triangle and uh
it's cut by um a segment that's parallel
to
one of the side so you now have some
line segments uh in which their
uh lenses are proportional so so that's
very
um fundamental thing in triangle
similarities
so you can use that um to um
to prove this problem and do some basic
computation
and the last part i'm going to show is
how you integrate
the graphics with the current graphics
system with the show so you have a
geometric
scene and it's graphics it can be
extracted and you put them in the show
um so this gives you exact a sort of
wordless proof to the problem so it's
very nice um
so the eventually you want to prove is
um all the the three lines that forming
a red triangle is exactly ekb
so if you do the computation you will
find there are two parallel
grams in the problem so it basically
transfer
one medium mf to kb and the other median
a a n to ek so
it happens that if d is uh uh that like
a one
third point of speed c and d is the
midpoint of uh
um dc kd is exactly a quarter length of
a cd
so you can just do that by algebra and
exactly the same thing for ae
so you transfer the egg am to ek so
eventually the
triangle you are looking you are going
to look at is
ekb or if you want to do that
before you find out without you can just
use sort of brute force way to compute
the euclidean distance of the
three medians in a and b this small
triangle
and the computer that with just one line
and you find the the first one plus
second one you could do third one so
it's
pythagorean properties so um
that's something you can i feel like
this
language in this part bridges algebra
and the geometry nicely so
it's very powerful and i
i just use that to solve the problems
online and feel it's very
smooth experience to to handle
everything okay
so yeah let's uh uh conclude everything
in the in the top when the geometric
scene follows the statement problem you
have seen that it's
just a dual translation and triangle
construct
or triangle centers um is just a very
powerful
uh functions to give the instance access
to
all the like important segments and like
you can find the properties or
attributes in the documentation center
that's very nice can you sorry i didn't
want to interrupt but our
our session will end automatically in a
little under 30 seconds
this is the last part i'm going to talk
um
yes um i think that's everything i'm
going to
cover thanks for attending
thank you all for coming
you